psvr2 gets a massive price tag Modern
Warfare 2 runs into more issues and it
takes two developer teasers the team's
next game all this on today's Gamespot
news
Sony has revealed the launch date and
price of the upcoming psvr 2. the good
news is the device is releasing very
soon the bad news is that it will cost
you more than a PS5 on February 22nd
2023 the psvr 2 will release for 550
which is 50 dollars more than the PS5
with a disk drive and 150 more than the
digital only PS5 Sony will also sell a
horizon call of the mountain bundle that
comes with the system and the game for
six hundred dollars while the psvr 2
sends controller charging station will
be offered on its own for fifty dollars
psvr 2 will be available to pre-order
starting November 15th from Sony's
Online Store pre-order registration
opens today November 2nd in addition to
the release date and pricing
announcement Sony revealed a bunch more
games you'll be able to play on the
system at launch in the vein of its
previous VR title until dawn Rush of
Blood that came out for the first psvr
developer Superman massive will be
releasing a similar experience under its
more recent dark pictures Banner a
horror game subtitled Switchback VR that
like rush of blood is a first person
shooter on a roller coaster in addition
shooter franchise Crossfire is coming to
the device with Sierra Squad the popular
VR title pistol whip is being ported
over and the city's series is getting a
VR installment for more info on all the
titles announced head to the link in the
description on the PC side of gaming
life a steam feature that was available
at Modern Warfare 2's launch has since
been disabled for the unfamiliar Family
Sharing is a steam feature that lets
family and friends have access to games
on your account any account can share a
game with up to 5 other accounts but
there are some restrictions the digital
copy is essentially shared between
accounts so two players cannot play at
the same time on different PCS the
feature is activated at the discretion
of the game publisher and there is an
option to turn it on or off in the steam
back end while the game launched with
this enabled a listing on Steam DB
States the feature was turned off on
Halloween preventing some players who
had access to the game from playing
further Activision has yet to make an
official comment but users have
speculated that Family Sharing can
enable cheetahs to avoid bans regardless
members of the Call of Duty Community
are generally unhappy with the change
citing the high price tag of the game
and the desire to let other members of
their household or family play without
buying a second copy something that you
won't be unhappy with is it takes two
developer hazelite's next game according
to Studio head Joseph Faris quote it's
definitely going in the right direction
Faris explained and it'll be something
really [ __ ] cool fores went on to
tease that whatever the game is it will
be a quote surprise in a good way trust
me it will blow your mind fares went on
to say that to quote when you load up
the game it's going to
but not before you
and also the Oscars okay that last quote
wasn't real but it totally could have
been I'm sorry I'm
gonna be gentler and that is it for
today's Gamespot news are you picking up
a psvr too what do you want from
hazelite's next title let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you here
tomorrow for more Gamespot news
thank you
[Music]